hey guys um let's get started so over
the last several weeks you've learned a
lot about many different learning
algorithms from linear regression so
this is regression to generalizing
models
Jennifer albums like GD n ie based most
recently support vector machines what
I'd like to do today is to start talking
about advice for applying learning
algorithms the fusional bottom of the
theory behind how to make good decisions
of what to do how to actually apply
these algorithms and so today I want to
discuss bias and variance and it turns
out you know I've built quite a lot of
machine learning systems and it turns
out that bias variance there's one of
those concepts this is sort of easy to
understand but hard to master what is it
lots of those was it all these board
games or sometimes a smartphone game say
he's to learn hard to master or
something like that
so Bosnians exactly one of those things
where I've had some PhD students you
know they're worked with me for several
years and then graduated and worked in
industry for a couple years after that
and and they actually tell me that you
know when they took machine learning at
Stanford they learned bias and variance
but as they progress for many years
their understanding of bias and variance
continues to deepen so I'm going to try
to accelerate your learning of what bias
and variance because I find that people
that understand this concept are much
more efficient in terms of how you
develop learning algorithms and meet
reverence work so let's talk about this
today and to be a recurring theme that
will come up with gain a few times in to
make several weeks as well um and then
we'll discuss regularization and talk
about how to reduce variance in learning
algorithms talk boy train dev test lists
and then also talk about a few model
selection and cross validation
algorithms oh and the C reminders for
today problem set one is due tonight
11:59 p.m. and if you are not yet ready
to submit it today late submissions are
accepted until Saturday evening Saturday
11:59 p.m. with the details of late
submissions written according to the
laid a policy written across websites if
so so definitely purchase em your home
on time today if for some reason you're
not able to the late submission which we
don't encourage anyone to take advantage
of but it is written on the course
website and problem set two will be
released shortly actually I think I was
already posted online and there's do two
weeks from now right and so so oh and
and and what I'm going to do today is
talk about their conceptual aspects of
this and if you want to see even more
math between these sort of conceptual
concepts at this Friday's discussion
section will be covering some of the
mathematical aspects of learning
theories such as error decomposition
uniform conversions and vc-dimension you
know what one interesting thing I've
learned really watching the evolution of
machine learning over many years is that
machine learning is a discipline as I
become less mathematical over the years
so I remember when you know machine
learning people used to worry about
computing the normal equations where X
transpose X inverse equals X transpose Y
how numerically stable is you a
numerical solver for solving the normal
equations of an inverting a matrix and
solving linear equations but because
numerical linear algebra has made
tremendous strides you now we just call
a linear you know linear algebra routine
to invert the matrix of solving linear
equations I got not worried about what
is numerically stable or no but once
upon the time lot of my friends in
machine learning were reading text books
on numerical optimization to figure out
of your you know formula for inverting a
matrix or really solving the system
equations was numerically stable and so
one of the trends have seen is that I
think you know three or four years ago
to understand violent variants there was
a certain mathematical theory that was
crucial to understand
and so I used to teach that in CS 229
but we decided we're constantly trying
to improve this class right but I
decided that that mathematical theory is
actually less crucial today if your main
goal is to make these albums were so we
still teach it but we're doing in the
Friday discussion section and that means
more time for the main lecture here to
talk more about the conceptual things I
think will help you build learning
algorithms as well as for the newer
topics like well we'll talk about the
random forest decision trees around the
forest and your network stinks so okay
so the solver buys a variance um let's
say you have this data set right I'm
gonna draw the same data set three times
okay so um let's say you have a housing
price prediction problem where this is
the size of the house and does the price
of the house um you know it looks like
if you fit a straight line to this data
maybe it's not too bad right but it
looks like if this data set seems to go
up and then curve downward a little bit
right and so maybe this is a slightly
better model if you fit a whole series
so this is if you fit a linear function
theta 0 plus theta 1 X but if you fit a
quadratic model maybe there's actually
physically a little bit better or you
could actually fit a high order
polynomial this is one two three four
five six examples serve you for the
fifth order polynomial let's say the 5x
to the fifth then you know you can
actually fit a function that passes
through all the points perfectly but
that doesn't seem like a great model for
this data
and so um to name these phenomenon the
function assuming you know the one in
the middle is what we like fitting a
quadratic function is maybe pretty
grateful service called just right
whoever as this example on the left it
under fits the data as it's not
capturing the trend that is maybe semi
evidence in the data and we say this
algorithm has high bias and the term
buyers you know the term bias has has
actually multiple meanings in the
English language we as a society want to
avoid you know racial bias and gender
bias and discrimination against people's
orientation and things like that so the
term bias and machine learning has a
completely separate meaning and it just
means that and and and it just means
that um this learning algorithm had very
strong preconceptions that data could be
fit by linear function this algorithm
has a very strong bias a very strong
preconception that the relationship
between pricing and haut size of house
is linear and this bias turns out not to
be true okay so there's a different
sense of bias then then the then the
then the other type of undesirable bias
where the boy this is society or which
which interesting he comes up in machine
learning as well in other contexts we
want our learning out of what those that
advises well there's different use of
the term and in contrast in this curve
on the right we say that this is a
overfitting the data and this algorithm
as high variance and the term high
variance comes from this intuition that
you happen to get these five examples
but if you know a friend of yours was to
collect data from series six six
examples if a friend of yours was to
collect you know a slightly different
set of six examples right so four friend
of yours with a rerun you collected
slightly different set of housings how
you know right then does our River will
fit some totally other varying function
on this and so the your predictions will
have very high variance if you think of
this as a version over different random
draws of the data so so the variations
if if a friend of yours does in the same
experiment just slightly different data
set just due to random noise then this
algorithm fitting a fifth order
polynomial results in a totally
different result so that's so we say
that this album has very high variance
there's a lot of variability in the
predictions this algorithm will make um
so one of the things we'll need to do is
identify if your learning algorithm so
we clean the learning algorithm it
almost never works the first time right
and so when I'm developing learning
algorithms my standard workflow is often
to train an algorithm often trained on
something quick and dirty and then try
to understand if the algorithm has a
problem of high bias or high variance if
it's under fitting ozone Fillion data
and I use that insight to decide how to
improve the learning algorithm okay and
I will say a lot more about how to
improve the learning algorithm will have
a menu of tools that we'll talk about in
the next couple weeks about how to
reduce bias or reduce variance of all of
your learning algorithms um I just
mentioned that the problems of bias
variance also hold true for
classification problems so
so let's say that's a binary
classification problem if you fit a
logistic regression model to this you
know straight line fit to the data maybe
that's not great
if you fitted logistic regression model
with a few nonlinear features so yeah
features x1 x2 if instead of using X 1
and X 2 as features you use additional
features x1 squared x2 squared x1 times
x2 x1 cube x2 it does a spy of X right
and you can have a small set of features
you choose by hand it's usually pretty
more features than this or use an SVM
kernel and use an SVM for this problem
then if you let's see if you have too
many features then you might actually
have a learning algorithm that fits the
decision boundary here that looks like
that right and this learning algorithm
actually gets perfect performance on the
training set but this overfits
excuse me I meant to make the colors
consistent sorry I meant to use red
thank you you get what I mean
um and there's only if you choose
somewhere in between you know there you
get something that that seems to be a
much better fit to the data the green
line seems to be a pretty good way of
separating positive and negative
examples that they're sort of just right
so similar to I guess I messed up the
COS idea well kind of but similar to
these colors here the blue line under
fits because it's not capturing trends
they're pretty apparent as data the the
orange line over fits is just much too
complicated hypotheses whereas the green
line is just right
so it turns out that in the area of you
know GPU computing ability to train
models of Lalla features one of the by
building a big enough model so take a
support vector machine if you add enough
features to it if you're high enough you
know dimensional feature space or if you
take a linear regression model religious
regression model and just add enough
features to it you can often overfit the
data and it turns out that one of the
most effective ways to prevent
overfitting is regularization so let me
describe what that is and are you
working today's lecture so this is and
regularization is a it'll be one of
those techniques that won't take that
long to explain it'll sound deceptively
simple but it's one of the techniques
that I use most often I feel like that
uses regularization in many many models
so so just because it doesn't sound
caught that comprise it or maybe won't
even take that long to explain today
don't underestimate how widely use it is
this is using it's not using every
single machine learning model but it's
used very very often so here's the idea
which is a stick linear regression right
so that's the optimization objective for
linear regression if you want to add
regularization you just add one extra
term here lambda times norm of theta
squared right sometimes you write lambda
over two to make some of the derivations
come out easier and what this does is it
takes your cost function for logistic
regression which you try to minimize
trying to minimize the squared error fit
to the data and you are creating an
incentive term for the algorithm to make
the parameters theta is smaller okay so
this is called the regularization term
and it turns out that um let's take the
linear regression overfitting example so
you know if you said long D equals zero
then it's just linear regression over
the fifth order polynomial features it
turns out that as you increase lambda or
lambda to some intermediate value or
depend on the scale of the data unless
he said lambda equals one then when you
solve for this minimization problem was
this augment problem for the value of
theta this term penalizes the parameters
being to be and it turns out that you
end up with a fit that looks a little
bit better right there maybe looks like
that
okay and by preventing the parameters
data from being too big you're making it
harder for the learning algorithm to
overfit the data it turns out fitting a
very high order polynomial like that may
result in value of stated is a very
large right and and then if you sent
lambda to be too large then you actually
end up in an under fitting regime okay
so they're usually be some optimal value
of lambda where it long equals zero
you're not using any regularization here
so it may be overfitting if lambda is
way too big then you're forcing all the
parameters to be too close to zero in
fact actually think about if mom it was
equals you know 10 to the 100 or some
ridiculously large number then you are
really forcing all the Thetas to be 0
right if all the phases are 0 then you
know then you're kind of fitting this
straight line right so that's it mom V
equals 10 to the 100 and so and this is
a very simple function which is the
function 0 right this function H of
theta of x equals 0 right approximately
0 this is a very simple function which
you get if you set down to be very large
and by dialing lambda between you know a
far too large value like 10 to the 100
compared to far too small value like
angle 0 you use you smooth the interplay
between this much to simple function of
H equals 0 and a much to complex
function okay so there is so that's
pretty it it so that's pretty much it
for regularization in terms of what you
need to is meant but if you like your
learning Outram may be overfitting add
this to your model and solve this
optimization problem and it will help
relieve overfitting more generally if
you are
let's see more generally if you have a
save logistic regression problem where
this is your cost function then to add
regularization I guess instead of min
this is a max right if you're applying
there just regression then this was the
original cost function then you can have
- long term or lambda over 2 there's
just defensive scaling of lambda times
the norm of theta squared and there's a
minus here because village is regression
we're maximizing around in minimizing
what this could be our merits in any of
the generalized linear model family as
well but by subtracting lambda times the
norm of theta squared this allows you to
also regularize the classification
algorithm such as logistic regression ok
um it turns out that and and I want to
make an analogy that where where all the
math details are true but we don't want
to talk about all the math details it
turns out that one of the reasons the
support vector machine doesn't over fit
too badly even though it has you know
you can be working infinite like a you
know infinite dimensional feature space
right so so why doesn't a support vector
machine just over fit like crazy we
showed on Monday that by using kernels
is sort of using an infinite dimensional
feature space right so why doesn't
always fit these crazy complicated
functions it just over today to say that
crazy it turns out and the theory is
complicated it turns out that you know
the optimization objective of the
support vector machine was to minimize
the norm of W squared this turns out to
correspond to maximizing the margin that
you measured margin SVM and it's
actually possible to prove that this has
a similar effect
as that right that this is why the
support vector machine despite working
infinite dimensional feature space
sometimes by forcing the parameters to
be small it's difficult for the support
vector machine to overfit the data too
much okay the theory to actually show
this is quite complicated yeah there's
actually very show that the class of
classifiers where this is what normal W
is small cannot be too complicating
cannot over fit basically but that's why
as you guys working you can work an
infinite dimensional features basis yeah
oh sure do you ever recognize per
element appearances um not really
and the problem with that is you know
give one let me give one more specific
example then come back to that right so
it turns out that um so we talked about
now you base as a text classification
algorithm it turns out that tell me
let's see if it's a classification
algorithm problem yes classify spam and
non-spam or classified it sentiment
positive or negative sentiment of a
tweet or something let's say you have a
hundred examples but you have ten
thousand dimensional features right so
let's see your features are these you
know take the dictionary a odd Bach and
so on it's a one zero one right so let's
you construct your feature vectors it
turns out that if you fit the just
regression to this type of data where
you have 10,000 parameters and hundred
examples
this will badly this will probably
overfit the data because you have but it
turns out that if you use the just
regress in with regularization this is
actually a pretty good algorithm for
text ossification and this will usually
in terms of performance accuracy you
know because this is Lee just regression
you need to implement gradient descent
or
to solve the good value parameters but
logistic regression with regularization
for text classification will usually
perform outperform naive Bayes on a
classification accuracy you standpoint
without regularization which is Russian
will value over fit this data and and to
to explain a bit more you know imagine
that you have a three dimensional
subspace where you have two examples
then all you can do is fit a straight
line right for the hyperplane to
separate these two examples but so one
rule of thumb for logistic regression is
that if you do not use regularization
it's nice if the number of examples is
at least on the order of the number of
parameters you want to fit right so this
is if you're not using regularization
it's nice if in fact I personally think
that I tend to use the jurors and the
only of the number of examples can be
maybe 10x bigger than the number of
examples because that's what you need to
have enough information to fit good
choices all these parameters but that's
a good not using regularization but if
you are using regularization then you
can fit you know even 10,000 parameters
right even with only 100 examples and
this will be a pretty decent text
classification out um the question you
had just now why don't we regularize per
parameter right so why don't we
let's see so I guess instead of lambda
you norm of theta squared it would be a
sum over J lambda J you know and theta J
squared right the reason we don't do
this is because you then end up with if
you have 10,000 parameters here you end
up with another 10,000 parameters here
and so choosing all this 10,000 lambdas
is as difficult that's just choosing all
these parameters in the first place so
we don't have a good way to do this
whereas when you talk about
cross-validation multi-session a little
bit we'll talk about how to choose maybe
one parameter lambda but but those
techniques won't work for choosing so
10,000 parameters
you'll see right yes thank you um yes so
in order to make sure that the different
launchers on the similar scale a common
pre-processing step we use in learning
algorithms is take two different
features
so for text classification if all the
features are zero one you can just leave
the features alone but if housing
classification if feature one is the
size of house which I guess ranges from
100 how big are the biggest houses no no
whatever let's see how's this girl from
500 square feet to 10,000 square feet
10,000 square foot really really big for
housing yes but then um feature x2 is
the number of bedrooms which proudly
ranges from like oh no wonder
I guess that some houses a ton of
dangerous but I think most houses have
been most 5 bedrooms right then these
features are on very different scales
and normalizing them to all be on a
similar scale so subtract out the mean
and divided by the standard deviation so
scale all of these things to be between
you know 0 1 or between minus 1 to 1
with would be a good pre-processing step
before applying these methods it turns
out that this will make gradient descent
run faster as well as a comic
pre-processing step to scale each
individual feature to be on a similar
range of values
so it's actually both searches repeated
why why don't support vector machines
ever too badly is it because there's no
small number of small vectors or is it
because of minimizing the penalty w um I
would say the formal argument relies
more on the latter so it turns out that
if you look at all the cost if you look
at all the class of functions sector
today to have a large margin that class
has low complexity formalized by low VC
dimension which you learned about in
Friday's discussion section if you want
to come to that and so it turns out that
the cause of all functions that separate
the data of a large margin is a
relatively simple class of functions but
and by simple cost functions I mean has
low VC dimension which talked about this
Friday and does any function within that
class of functions is not too likely to
overfit so it is convenient the support
vector machine is relatively no number
of support vectors but there you could
imagine other algorithms of a very large
number of support vectors
that's all as the large margin is still
a local Mexican so I would say the game
oh sure yes so is it possible though so
yes so one of the so yes so in general
models that have high bias to enter
under fit and models of high variance
sent to overfit
we use these terms overfilled high
variance under fit hi buyers
not quite and they have very similar
meanings right their first frustration
assume they didn't mean the same thing
one thing we'll see later a two weeks
from now is we'll talk about algorithms
with high bias and high variance so this
is a and actually one way to think of
high bias in high variance was hopeful
Dominator is your data set that looks
like this and if somehow your classifier
has very high complexity there's a very
very complicated function but for some
reason is still not fitting your data
well right so that'd be one way to have
high bias and high variance which does
happen
all right
so to wrap up the discussion on
regularization this one so mechanically
the way you implement regularization is
by adding that penalty on the norm of
the parameters so that's what you
actually implement it turns out that
there's another way to think about
regularization so you remember when we
talked about the new linear regression
we talked about minimizing squared error
and then later on we saw that linear
regression was maximum likelihood
estimation on a certain journalize
linear model using a using using using a
Gaussian distribution as the expertise
for the exponential family is a member
of the extension family it turns out
that does a similar point of view you
can take on the regularization algorithm
that we just saw which is let's say s is
the training set so um given a training
set you want to find the most likely
value of theta right and so by Bayes
rule P of theta given s is P R s given
theta times P of theta divided by P of s
and so if you want to pick the value of
theta that's the most likely value of
theta given the data you saw then
because the denominator is just a
constant this is our max over theta P of
x given theta times P of theta
and so if you're using logistic
regression then the first term is this
and in the second term is P of theta
where this is the you know logistic
regression models they write or any
generalized linear model and it turns
out that if you assume P of theta is
Gaussian so if we assume your phases
follow theta the probability on theta is
Gaussian with mean zero and some
variance tau squared I so in other words
a p of theta is you know 1 over root 2
pi I guess this be determinant of tau
squared I write e to the negative theta
transpose tau squared i inverse so the
Gaussian probability as follows it turns
out that if this is your prior
distribution for theta and you plug this
in here and you take logs compute the
max and so on then you end up with
exactly the regularization technique
that we found just now ok and so in
everything we've been doing so far we've
been taking a frequentist interpretation
I guess the two main schools of
statistics are there frequences school
of statistic and the Bayesian school
statistic and they used to be sort of
Titanic academic debates about which is
the right one but I think
the statisticians have gotten together
and and kind of made peace and and then
it goes really between these two more
and more these days maybe not not all
the time later but the frequency school
statistic we say that there is some data
and we want to find the value of theta
that makes the data as likely as
possible and that's where we got maximum
likelihood estimation all right and in
the frequency school statistics we view
there as being some true value of theta
out in the world that is unknown and so
there is some true value of theta that
generated all these housing prices and
our goal is to estimate this true
parameter in the Bayesian school of
statistics we say that theta is unknown
but before you see even any data you
already have some prior beliefs about
how housing prices are generated out in
the world and your prior beliefs are
captured in a prior distribution denoted
by P of theta so this is called a
Gaussian prior and we say that and and
and if you look at this Gaussian prior
excuse me it's quite reasonable you're
saying that before you seen any data on
average I think the parent is of theta
have mean zero because I don't know if
each theta is positive negative so
giving them a zero seems reasonable and
most things in the world I thought since
I just assumed that my prior on Thetas
Gaussian so you know because we could
debate if this is a the right assumption
but it's not totally unreasonable right
but they say well actually I think you
know for the next linear regression
problem I'm gonna work on next week and
I have no idea what I'm gonna work on
what I'm gonna apply linear regression
in next week it was actually not too bad
an assumption to say you know my priors
is Gaussian and in the Bayesian view of
the world our goal is to find the value
of theta that is most likely after we
have seen the data okay
and so this is called map estimation
we're sense for maximum a-posteriori
estimation so this is actually the map
estimator I get the odd max of this
right there's the map or the maximum a
posteriori estimates of theta which
means look at the data compute the
Bayesian posterior distribution on theta
and pay the value of theta that's most
likely okay and so one of the things you
do in the problem set that was just
released is no is actually show this
equivalence as well as plug in a
different prior States or other than the
Gaussian prior you experiment about
whether P of a is the Laplace prior and
define and derive a different map okay
wait sorry few said again yes OSE oh yes
current difference we need these to be
seen as recognize diversity is not right
yes so so MOU here corresponds to you
know the average salary without
regularization and this procedure here
corresponds to having regularization it
turns out that free consistent decisions
can also use regularization it's just
that they don't try to justify it
through amazing a prior they shouldn't
say so if your frequency statistic if
your frequentist statistics your job is
a wake up and come up with an algorithm
to estimate this you know true value of
theta then because it's out in the world
you can come of any procedure you want
and then spa your procedure you can add
a regularization term I think there's a
lot of these debates in frequences and
patients are more philosophical I think
as a machine learning person as an
engineer I don't really you know I think
the philosophical debates are lovely but
I just I just like my stuff to work so
so I decided so we can say so
frequencies can also in fin
regularization it's just that they say
this is part of the algorithm they
invented rather than derived from a
Bayesian prior alright cool so
let's talk about so in in a discussion
on regularization and choosing the
degree of polynomial so let's see let's
say I plot a chart where on the
horizontal axis I plot model complexity
so how complicated is your model so for
example to the right of this curve could
be a very high degree polynomial and
what you find is that as you increase
model complexity your training error if
you do not regularize right so if you
fit a linear function which I found any
cubic function and so on you find that
the higher the degree of a polynomial
the bed to your training error because
you know a fifth order polynomial always
facilitate better than a fourth order
polynomial if if you if you do not
regular eyes but what we saw with the
original picture was that the ability of
the algorithm to generalize kind of goes
down and then starts to go back up right
and so if you were to have a separate
test set and evaluate your classifier on
a set of data that the algorithm hasn't
seen so far so measure how well the
album generalizes to a different novel
set of data then if you fit a linear
function then this under fits if you
take the fifth order polynomial this
over fits and this somewhere in between
right that is just right okay and this
curve is true for regularization as well
so say you apply linear regression with
10000 features to a very small shiny
example if launder was much too big then
they will under fit if lambda was 0 so
you're not recognizing at all then it
will over fit and there will be some
intermediate value of lambda that's not
too big not too small that you know
balances overfitting and underfitting
okay so um what I like to do next is
describe a mechanistic as you a few
different mechanistic procedures for
trying to find this point in the middle
right and so
um so given the data set what we'll
often do is take your data set and split
it into different subsets and a good
hygiene is the ticket agent train to
Train dev and test sets so if you have
say 10,000 examples and you're trying to
carry out this model selection problem
so for example let's say you're trying
to decide what order polynomial you want
to fit right or you're trying to choose
the value of lambda or you're trying to
choose the value of tau there was the
bandwidth parameter in a locally
weighted regression that you saw on the
problem set and if that we saw with a
locally weighted regression
all right so oh you're trying to choose
a value C in a support vector machine so
remember the SVM objective was actually
this write what you know subject to some
of the things but for the unknown soft
margin they were southbound on Wednesday
total on Monday you're trying to
minimize the norm of W and then there
was this additional parameter C that
trades off how much you insist on
classifying every training example
perfectly so whether you're trying to
make which of these decisions are trying
to make how do you you know choose a
polynomial size or choose lambda or
choose tau or choose parameter C which
also has this bias variance trade-off
there will be some valleys that see the
too large and some valleys of C that's
you small
so here's one thing you can do which is
let's see so split your training data s
into a subset which I'm gonna call the
real training set as subscript train and
in some subset which we call as
subscript dev and F stands for
development and then later we'll talk
about a separate test set and so what
you can do is train each model and by
model I mean um option for the degree of
polynomial on s train Soviet evaluating
a menu of models right so let's say this
is model 1 model 2 and so on up to model
5 up to some number they can train each
of these models on the first subset of
the data and then get some hypothesis
that's called H I and then measure the
error on s death which is the second
subset of data called the development
set and pick the one
so rather than and and I want to
contrast this with an alternative
procedure right so the two cents of the
day two substances they talk about tests
and data training set and development
sets and after training first of all the
world second apollomon or third all
polynomial on the training set evaluate
all of these different models on the
separate held up development sets and
then pick the one with the lowest error
on the development center okay but one
thing to not do would be to evaluate all
these algorithms instead on the training
set and then pick the one with the
lowest error on the training set right
why not what what goes wrong when you do
that
Yeah right you just over fit I were you
over it
yeah yep cool right so if you use this
procedure you always end up picking the
fifth order polynomial right because the
more complex our rhythm will always do
better on the training set so if you do
this this will always cause you to say
let's use the fifth order polynomial or
the highest possible order polynomial so
this won't help you realize in the
housing price prediction example the
second order polynomial is a benefit to
the data and that's why for this
procedure if you evaluate your models
error or the separate development set
that the album did not see during
training this allows you to hopefully
pick a model that neither overfits no
longer fits and in this example
hopefully you find that there will be
the second order polynomial right the
one that's just right in between that
actually does best on your development
center okay now and then you know if you
are if you are publishing an academic
paper on machine learning then this
procedure has looked at the training set
as was the development set right so this
this procedure this piece of code is you
know is - in these decisions is tune the
parameters the training set and is tuned
the decision on the degree of polynomial
to the DEF set and so if you want to
know if you want to publish a paper to
say oh my algorithm achieves 90%
accuracy of this data set is not valid
to report the result on the dev set
because the algorithm has already been
optimized to the data set in particular
information about what's the most what's
the best degree polynomial was derived
from the DEF set from the development
set and so if you're publishing a paper
or you want to report an unbiased result
evaluate the algorithm
separate test set as a test and report
that error okay and so if you're
publishing your paper if you can say
good hygiene to report the error on a
completely separate test set that you
did not in any way shape or form look at
during the development of your model
doing the training procedure or Devon
test is there any different by Mike it
depends on the jet size it depends on
the size of the data set and so it turns
out that actually let me let me give an
example actually so let's say you're
trying to fit a degree of polynomial and
you want to choose right to death error
so you can for the first second third
fourth degree polynomial and so after
fitting all of these let's say that the
squared error right to just use round
numbers is ten five point one five point
zero nine seven ten okay just to just to
use round numbers for illustrative
purposes if you're using the def error
to pick the best hypothesis to pick the
best classifier you would say that using
a fifth order polynomial against you for
point nine squared error right but did
you really earn that four point nine
squared error or did you just get lucky
because there is some noise and so maybe
all of these actually have error that
close to five point zero but some are
just higher so much as lower and you
just got a little bit lucky that on the
DEF set this did better which is why if
you look in your deaf set error your def
set error is a biased estimate
right and so where's there a very large
test set there is a very large test said
maybe the true numbers are 10 5 5 5 7 10
by your actual expected squared errors
it's just that because of little bit of
noise you got lucky and you reported 4.9
and so this would be a bad thing to do
in an economic paper right because of
what you earned was an error of 5.0 you
didn't earn an error 4.9 that's just
that because you're overfitting a little
bit and the DEF set you chose the thing
that looked best for the DEF set but
your algorithm didn't actually keep that
error it's just because of noise okay so
so now in some cells consider good
practice to report so reporting on the
death error is in isn't isn't really a
valid unbiased procedure and then
question
yeah so what one of the just a
researcher said yes you're right one of
the problems with some of the machine
learning benchmarks that people worked
on for a long time is does this
unavoidable mental overfitting the
people call them to use the Z's and
everyone's worked my same trying to
publish the best numbers the same test
said so the academic committee on
machine learning does have some amount
of overfitting to the standard
benchmarks that people worked on for a
long time and this is an unfortunate
result when the testing is very very
large the amount of overfitting is
probably smaller but when the test set
is not big enough then the overfitting
result can cause sometimes even research
papers to publish results that are
you're probably over fit to the data set
and so I think there's actually one
stand the academic benchmark because the
dataset called seefox quite small so
it's actually very same research paper
analyzing results on C far arguing that
some fraction of the progress that was
made was actually perhaps researchers
unintentionally overfitting to this
dataset okay oh my the way um one thing
I do when I'm building you know
production machine learning systems so
when I'm when I'm shipping a product
right I just like build with speech
recognition to them and just make it
work I just wanna and not and if I'm not
trying to publish a paper and not try
and make some claim sometimes I don't
bother to the test set right so and and
that means I don't know the true error
of the system sometimes but I'm very
conscious of that if I don't allow data
sometimes I'm gonna decide to just not
have the test set and it means I just
don't try to report the tested number I
can report a Jeff said number which I
know is bias and I just don't report a
tested number I don't do this in your
publishing your academia paper right
this is not good if you're publishing a
paper on making claims on the outside
but already doing is building a product
and not writing a paper distance this is
actually
okay yeah yeah okay good that's let me
let me get to that good so um the next
topic about some of the train dev test
blitz is how do you decide how much data
should go into you should these three
subsets um so I can tell its owner just
tell you the historical perspective and
then a modern perspective um
historically the rule of thumb was you
take your training said right take your
training set s and then you would send
you know one rule of thumb that you see
a lot of people refer to is 70% train
right 30% tests this is one common rule
of thumb that you just hear a lot or
maybe you have if you if you don't have
a test said if you're not doing model
selection if you just if you already
picked them although not realizing or
maybe you have people use you know 60
percent range 20 percent 20 percent
tests right so these are rules of thumb
that people use to give and these are
decent rules of thumb when you don't
have a massive data set see if you have
100 tons of examples maybe of a thousand
examples may be several thousand
examples I think these rules of thumb
are perfectly fine what I'm seeing is
that as you move to machine learning
problems with really really giant data
sets the percentage of data you sent a
dev and test shrinking and so here's
what I mean let's say you have 10
million examples decent-size not giant
but you can resize so let's take this is
actually pretty good rule of thumb if
you're a small desert if you have you
know a 5 min examples this perfectly 5
rule of thumb to use but if you have 10
million examples then you know you have
6 million 2 million too many
right trained deaf tests and the
question is do you really need two
million examples to estimate the
performance of your final classifier
sometimes you do if you're working on
online advertising you know which I have
done and you're trying to increase your
ad click-through rate by 0.1 percent
because it turns out increasing our
click-through rates by 0.1 percent which
I've done multiple times turns out to be
very lucrative then you actually need a
very large data set to measure these
very very small improvements because to
increase an ad click-through rate by 0.1
you might have llama projects you might
have 10 projects each of which increases
at click-through rate by 0.01% right and
so to measure these very different small
differences in algorithm one does 0.01
percent better than algorithm B but so
you need a wall date so to tease out
that very small difference so if you're
in the business of teasing out these
very small differences you actually need
very large test sets but if you are
comparing different algorithms and one
algorithm is you know 2% better or even
1% better than the other algorithm then
with a thousand examples maybe right a
thousand examples may be enough for you
to distinguish between these much larger
differences so my recommendation for
choosing the Jeff and Tess says is
choose them to be big enough that you
have been updated to make meaningful
comparisons between different algorithms
and if you suspect your algorithms will
be Rhian performance by 0.01% you just
need a law data to distinguish that
right so if you have 100 examples then
you know if one algorithm has 90%
accuracy and one algorithm has 90 point
zero one percent accuracy then unless
you have at least a thousand examples
and maybe ten thousand or more you just
can't see this very small difference
right if you're a hundred examples you
just can't measure this very small
difference so my advice is choose your
dev and test sets to be big enough that
you could see the differences in the
performance of algorithms that you have
yet that you roughly expected
and then you don't need to make your jab
in chest as much larger than that and I
would usually then just put the data you
don't need an indefinite essence back in
the training set so when you're working
a very large data set say you know
million or ten million one hundred
million examples what you see is that
the percentage of data that goes into
dev and test tends to be much smaller so
it might be so you see for example maybe
90 percent train you know five percent
dev and five percent test right or even
smaller or even one percent one percent
depending on how much states you really
need to measure to the level of accuracy
you need the differences that
performance your algorithms okay all
right um just to give this whole
procedure a name what we just did here
between the train and dev set this
procedure that we have is called holdout
cross-validation and sometimes to
distinguish this from other cross
validation procedures we'll talk about
in a minute sometimes this is called
simple hold our cross validation we'll
talk about some other hold our cross
validation procedures in a second and
and the dev set is sometimes also called
the our cross validation set
right so sometimes you people use
sometimes you hear people say you know
we're going to use a cross-validation
set that means roughly the same thing as
a dev set okay so in the normal workflow
of developing a learning algorithm when
you're given the data said I was
splitted into a training set and a dev
set oh and I used to say
cross-validation set but
cross-validation is just a mouthful so I
think just motivated by the reducing
number of syllables because we're using
the cause of so often more and more
people just call the dev set but it
means you're roughly the same thing
right so so when I'm building a machine
learning system I'll often take the days
that splits into train and dev and if
you need a test set and also a test set
and then keep on fitting the parameters
to the training set and evaluating the
performance of your algorithm on the
Jeff set and so of using that to come up
with new features choose the model size
choose the regularization parameter
lambda really try out lots of different
things and spend you know several days
or weeks to optimize the performance on
the DEF set and then when you want to
know how well is your algorithm
performing to then evaluate the model on
the test set right and and the thing to
be careful not to do is to make any
decisions about your model using the
test set because then then you're signed
to fit the data to the test set there's
no longer than bias estimate so and one
thing that is actually okay to do is if
you have a team that's working on a
problem if every week they measure the
performance on the test set and report
out on the chart right you know the
performance of the test set that's
actually okay you can evaluate the model
multiple times on the test set you can
actually give out a weekly report saying
this week for our online advertising
system we have this result in a test set
one week later with distres on test set
won't be later this code says that it's
actually okay to evaluate your algorithm
repeatedly on the test set what's not
okay is to use those evaluations to make
any decisions about your learning
algorithm so for example if one day you
notice that your model is doing worse
this weekend last week on the test set
if you use that to revert back to an
older model
then you've just made a decision that's
based on the test set and your test set
is no longer bias but if all you do is
report all the result but not make any
decisions based on the test set
performance such as whether to revert to
an earlier model then you feel that it
is actually legitimate it's actually
okay to keep on you know user use the
same test set to track your your team's
performance over time okay all right
good so when your very large data says
this is a procedure of you know
developing for defining the I trained F
in test sets and this procedure can be
used to choose the model of polynomial
it can also be used to choose the
regularization parameter lambda or the
parent st or the parameter tau from a
locally weighted regression now one of
you have a very small data set so it
turns out that so I'm going to leave out
the test set for now let's just assume
you're some circuit tester I'm not gonna
worry about that for now um but let's
say you have a 100 examples right if
you're going to split this into you know
17 in the training set in s subscript
train and 30 in s def then you train
your algorithm on 70 examples instead of
a hundred examples and so I've actually
worked on a few healthcare problems okay
most of my PhD students including Anand
work doing a lot of work on machine
learning advisor healthcare and so we're
actually working a few data says in
healthcare where you know every training
example correspond to some patient that
sometimes had a you know unfortunate
disease or if ever you're working or if
every example correspond it to injecting
a patient with a drug and seeing what
happened to the patient right sometimes
there's literally lot of blood and pain
that goes into collecting every example
and if you have a hundred examples to
hold out 30 of them for the purpose of
model selection using only 70s
100 examples it seems like you're
wasting a lot of data there was
collected through a lot of you know
literal pain right so is there a way to
say do model selection so just choose
the degree of polynomial without quote
slightly wasting so much of the data
there is a procedure that you should use
only if you have a small dataset only if
you're worried about the size oh and the
other disadvantage of this is evaluate
your model only on 30 examples and that
seems really small right yeah okay can
you just find more data to evaluate your
models as well so there's a procedure
that you should use only if you have a
small data set called k-fold
cross-validation or CAFO cv and this is
in contrast to simple cross-validation
but this is the idea which is let's say
this your training set s you know x1 y1
down to x say 100 by 100 what we're
going to do is take the training set and
divide it into K pieces so for the
purpose of illustration I'm going to use
K equals 5 when I'm just to make the
writing on the board same pen k equals
10 is typical but so what you do is um
take your data set and divide it into
five different subsets of in this
example you would have 20 examples I'm
doing 100 examples divided into 5
subsets is that 20 examples in each
subset and what you do is from I equals
1 to K train
I give fit parameters on K minus 1
pieces
and then test on the remaining one piece
and then your average right so in other
words when K is equals five we're going
to loop through five times in the first
iteration we're going to Train on these
and test on the last one fifth of the
data so we'll hold out the last one
fifth of the data trained on the rest
and test on that and then in the second
iteration through this for loop we'll
train on pieces one two three and five
and test on piece number four and we get
the number and then you hold out this
third piece trained on the others test
on this and so on so you're doing five
times we're on each time you leave out
one fifth of the data trained on the
remaining four fifths and you evaluate
the model on that final one fifth okay
and so if you're trying to choose the
degree of polynomial what you would do
is I guess for you know D equals one to
five
right so you do this procedure for a
first-order polynomial fit you fit a
linear regression model of five times
each time on four fifths in the model
and testin remaining one fifth and you
repeat this whole procedure for the
quadratic function repeat this whole
procedure for the cubic function and so
on and after doing this for every order
polynomial from serve one two three four
five you would then pick the degree of
polynomial that oh and sorry and then
for each of these models you then
average the five SS you have for this
error okay and then after doing this you
will pick the degree of polynomial that
did best according to this according to
this metric right and then maybe you
find it a second-order polynomial does
this and now you actually end up with
five classifiers right because you know
at five classifies each one fits on
four-fifths of the data and then and and
there's a there's a final optional step
which is the refit the model on all 100%
of the data so if you want you could
keep five classifiers around and output
their predictions but then you're
keeping five pass files around this may
be a bit more common now that you've
chosen to use a second-order polynomial
to just refit them all the ones on all
100% of the data okay
and so the advantage of k-fold
cross-validation is that instead of
leaving out 30% of your data for your
dev set on each iteration you're only
leaving out one over k of your data I
use K equals five for illustration but
in practice Kinkos ten is by far the
most common choice that we use of
sometimes seeing people use K equals 20
but quite rarely but if used K equals 10
then on each iteration you're leaving
out just one tenth of the data 10% in
later rather than 30% of the data
and so this procedure compared to simple
cross-validation it makes more efficient
use of the data because you're holding
out you know only 10% of the data on
each generation the disadvantage of this
is completely very expensive that you're
now fitting each model ten times instead
of just once okay but but then when you
have a small data set this is actually a
better procedure than simple
cross-validation if you don't mind the
competition expense of fitting each
model ten times this does this actually
lets you get away with holding on this
data and then there's one even more
extreme version of this which you should
use if you have very very small data
sets so sometimes you might have an even
smaller if they set you know if you're
doing a class project with twenty
examples this that's that's small even
by today's machine learning standards so
this does an extreme version of k-fold
cross-validation called leave one out
cross validation which is if you say a
equals m right so in other words here's
your training set
maybe twenty examples so you're gonna
divide this into as many pieces as you
have training examples and what you do
is leave out one example trained on the
other nineteen and test on the one
example you held out and then leave out
a second example trained on the other
nineteen and tested one example you held
out and do that twenty times and then
you averaged this over the twenty
outcomes evaluate how good different
orders of polynomial the huge downside
of this is this is completely very very
expensive because now you need to train
your algorithm m times so you you kind
of never do this unless M is really
small I personally have I pretty much
never use this procedure unless Emma is
a hundred or less that yes you you know
if your model isn't too complicated you
can afford to fill in linear regression
model hundred times like it's not too
bad right so so if if M is less than 100
you could consider this procedure but if
if M is a thousand fifteen alidium
although fitting them although a
thousand times it seems to come out the
world and usually use k-fold
cross-validation instead but if you do
have twenty examples then you know I
would then if you have twenty examples I
would probably use this procedure and
somewhere between twenty and 50s
maybe we're not switch over from leave
one out okay for cross-validation
oh yeah so right so since you have K
estimates say ten tenesmus you're using
10-fold cross-validation
can you measure the variance on those
ten estimates it turns out that those
ten estimates are correlated because
each of the ten classifiers
eight eight eight out of nine of the
sense of data they trained on overlap so
there was some very interesting theory
result there's some research papers
written by micro currents actually it
was like a long time ago trying to
understand how correlated are these ten
estimates and from a theoretical point
of view the we as far as I know the
latest error result shows that this is
not the worst estimate than training
error but no but but maybe it's showing
us in practice is not you could measure
it but we don't really trust that
estimate of variance because we think
all 10s mr. Hardy
Carlita Oh at least somewhat correlated
where do I find using k-fold
cross-validation debugging um if you
have a very small training set then
maybe yes but deep learning algorithms
depend on the details right sometimes it
takes so long to train that training
training training on your network 20
times you know seems like a pain unless
unless you have enough data unless uh
unless you're near a network is quite
small right so it's rarely done with a
deep learning algorithm but if you're
frankly if you have so little data if
you're 20 training examples you know
there are other techniques that you
probably need to use the Bruce
performance such as transfer learning or
just more hand engineering of input
features or something else sorry tell
you oh sorry thank you for asking that
this average step no I meant averaging
the test errors so here you will have
trained ten classifiers and you know
when you evaluate it on the Left I won
ten for the data you get it really you
get a number right so you're looping ten
times hold on one part trained on the
others test on this part you left out
and so that would give you a number like
oh say oh when you test on this part you
left out the squared error was 5.0 and
then do it again square error was five
point seven squared was two point eight
so by average I meant average those
numbers and the average of those numbers
is your estimate of the error of a you
know third order polynomial for this
problem so this is an averaging instead
of real numbers that you got from this
is so so this loop gives you K real
numbers and so this is averaging those
cave
numbers to estimate for this alternate
how could a cost 5 with a degree
polynomials okay well I should love
questions there's one thing I like over
go ahead but it's lost two good I see
sure yes I'm sure in something other
than f1 score with the doing other than
average yes it would
having f1 school is complicated yes I
think I think we'll talk actually so
this week Friday we'll talk about
learning theory next week next Friday
were talking about performance
evaluation metrics so I'll talk about
one school all right oh sure honey
sample the data in these says so for the
purpose of this cause assuming all your
data comes to the same distribution oh I
will use the randomly shuffle again in
the era of machine learning and big data
there's one other interesting trend is
which which just wasn't true 10 years
ago which is we're increasingly trying
to train and test on different stats
we're trying to you know train on data
collected in one context and apply to
totally different context suggests we're
trying to you know train on speech
collected on your cell phone because
we've all that data and trying to apply
it to a small speaker where it was
collected on a different microphone in
your cell phone or something so if you
are doing that and the way you set your
train to have test fit it's a bit more
complicated um I wasn't going to talk
about in this class you want to learn
more I think that the sound of that
cause I mentioned I was working on this
book machine learning journey so that
book is finished and if you go to this
website you can get a copy of it for
free that talks about that and I also
talked about this more CS 2:30 English
which goes more into the Big Data but
you could you know go and learn machine
you can also read all about it in
machine learning learning if the
training test
different distribution yeah but random
softly it would be a good default if you
think your training test that's not too
different all right just one last thing
with a cover real quick which is a
feature selection and so so them justice
drag one so sometimes you have a lot of
features so actually let's take text
classification you might have ten
thousand features because one in the ten
thousand words
but you might suspect that while the
features are not important right you
know there won't be whether the worthy
is called a stop where whether the word
D appears an email not doesn't really
tell you this family of spam because of
where the a of you know these are called
stop words they don't tell you much
about the content of the email but so if
a lot of features sometimes one way to
reduce overfitting is to try to find a
small subset of the features that are
most useful for your task right and so
um
this takes judgment there are some
problems like computer vision where you
have a lot of features Chris one into
there being a lot of pixels in every
image but probably every pixel is
somewhat relevant so you don't want to
select a subset of pixels for most
configuration tasks but there are some
other problems where you may have lot of
features then you suspect the way to
prevent overfitting is to find a small
subset of the most relevant features for
your task so feature selection is a
special case of model selection that
applies to when you suspect that even
though you have ten thousand features
maybe only 50 of them are highly
relevant right and so one example if you
are measuring a lot of things going on
in a truck in order to figure out if the
truck is about to break down right you
might preventive maintenance you might
measure hundreds of variables or many
hundreds of variables but you might
secretly suspect that there are only a
few things that you know predict when
the truck is about to go down so good
preventive maintenance so if you suspect
that's the case then feature selection
will be a reasonable approach to try
right and so here's the I'll just write
out one algorithm which is start with
this is script F equals the empty set of
features and then you're repeatedly try
adding each feature I so f and c which
single feature addition most improves
the DEF set performance and then step
two is a go ahead and commit to add that
feature
so let me illustrate this with pictures
so let's say you have all five features
X 1 through X 5 and in practice are you
more like X 1 through X 500 oh I went
through 10,000 I'll just use 5 so start
off with an empty set of features and
you know train a linear classifier with
no features so the model is H of X
equals theta 0 right with no features so
this won't be very good normal but see
how well this does on your death set so
the thinking were average the Y's right
so it's not really normal
NIC's so this is step one in the second
iteration you would then take each of
these features and add it to the empty
set so you can try the empty set plus x1
and he said plus x2 and he said plus x5
and for each of these you infinite
corresponding models so for this one you
fit the picture of x equals theta 0 plus
theta 1 x5 so let's try adding one
feature to your model and see which
model best improves your performance on
the DEF set right and let's say you find
it adding feature two is the best choice
so now what we do is set the set of
features to be x2 for the next step you
would then consider starting of X 2 and
adding X 1 or X 3 or X 4 or X 5 so if
your model is already using the feature
X 2
what's the other feature what additional
feature most helps you algorithm and
let's say this X 4 right fit for models
see which one does best and now you
would commit to using the features X 2
and X 4 and you kind of keep on doing
this keep on adding features greedily
keep on adding features one at a time to
see which single feature addition helps
improve your album demos and
and and you can keep iterating until
adding more features now hers
performance and then pick what whichever
feature subset allows you to have the
best possible performance which I've
said okay so this is a special case of
model selection called forward search
it's called forward search we're
starting empty set of features and
adding features one at a time there's a
procedure called backward search which
can read about that we start with all
the features remove features one other
time but this would be a reasonable
feature section algorithm the
disadvantage of this is is quite
computationally expensive but this can
help you select a decent set of features
okay several running a little bit late
let's break oh so I think I was meant to
be on the road next week but because is
still unable to teach I think we'll have
Rafael teach decision trees next week
and then also can talk about networks we
okay so let's break for today and then
maybe we'll see some of you at the
Friday discussion